it's
God it's
God it's God okay so now what's the nil
what's the what's the what's the what's
the and I'm the Man to answer that
question all right so what is the NG
okay so the NG come
on theel was the Revelation that was
given to Jesus Christ now what was that
I'll explain so Matthew Mark Luke and
John right these are biographies about
the life and Ministry of Jesus Christ so
we yes so it records so it records some
of the life teaching and message of
Jesus Christ but the caveat here what is
the Muslim
position uh a lot of the times you'll
hear Avery say that the Quran confirms
the gospels and that is half true
because he stops at the in the middle of
the verse and I want you to admit that
you stop in the middle of verse admit it
you stop in the middle of verse where it
says the one that says it confirms the
um the previous scripts there's a bunch
of those what do you mean I stop in the
middle he stops in the middle of the
verse where it says
uh that we have revealed this book
meaning the Quran and Truth
confirming what came before that is
between their hands from the book and a
supreme authority over it as an as a
supreme author he always leaves the part
out where it says what is the because
because we confirm the inil but we say
that we have to view it in the lens of
the Quran I'm not talking about
confirmation right now I'm just asking
what it is what the Quran what conforms
so what conforms with the Quran is the
injil what doesn't conform with the
Quran isn't the injil and that can
include or does include actually Matthew
Mark Luke and John so you're saying we
have the inel uh not the complete inel
so we have some of the some of theel yes
so the inil we can find in our Bible yes
okay so why why is that but that's but
who but whoever disputed that but
whoever disputed that you now you now
you know that you got an entire Squad of
Muslims that's saying that Matthew Mark
Luke and John is not the it contains
parts of the in because because the
verse in the Quran going back to it
says it doesn't say it says it confirms
what is between their hands from the
book and what is the book it's it's
Matthew Mark Luke and John so it says
it's from the but whatever conforms
whatever conforms to the Quran is true
because it also
says is the supreme authority it's the
overlooker Nob C said is the supreme
authority in which whatever conforms
this is whatever conforms to the Quran
we agree with whatever disagrees with
the Quran is false so the the Quran is
the can I give you somebody now so
here's Jal here's alabi they say MIM
just means uh uh multiple meetings
brother witness none of them ever say
that it's a supreme authority yes you
know why because in the very
in the very next verse I let you talk
but but this is the point I know what
you're going to say okay go ahead go
ahead go ahead thank you so you have
Scholars that disagree with epic's
interpretation so who do we go with I'm
going to choose my I'm going to choose
our top read because they agree with me
it's the Pik me you know so so because
it muhamad is Guardian witness um overse
overseer it's not a judge over the
previous really are you sure you want to
go with that absolutely because in the
very next very next ay it says
judge between then by what by what Allah
has revealed there within judge between
who between the the scriptures no wait
cuz it says judge between them um by
what has been revealed to you and do not
follow their vain desires do scriptures
have desires no it says judge between
them using what Allah has revealed
between who but that includes their
scriptures and their people and that's
where you that's where you messed up no
I didn't mess up there so it says it
says it says judge between them by what
uh has been revealed to you and do not
follow their vain desires books don't
have desires yeah but it's it's talking
about people correct it's talking about
people but it's also talking about their
scriptures no it doesn't yes it is no it
says it's
judging is a supreme authority over and
if IB C says I don't care what tabar say
I don't care what I says we can both but
it is an inter okay and I don't care and
I don't care that oin some interpret it
meaning to know or to declare so so what
are we going to do we're going to have
to agree can't you can't give me a
scholar that disagrees with what I said
I give a scholar that dis because no
there's plenty of Scholars that say this
interpretation of no in Matthew 13:32
refers to Jesus's limited human where do
they deny that it's not uh declarative
where do they deny that what what do you
mean where do they deny that see this is
the this is the part where where we're
at but okay argument from Silence me you
can't use argument from Silence AR if
they have a position they have to stick
cut me off bro you're cutting me off
it's not an argument from Silence we
have what they say so when we have what
they say we can see how they applied it
we see alabi we see Jalan we see YF Ali
and I can give you others they all say
that m not a scholar translat a
translator can you translate the Quran
and not be a scholar yes yes you're just
you could you could you could just know
Arabic translate this is no because this
is a matter of language not comment you
have to no you have to be educated and
you have to be a scholar in order
toab
Arab schar not a Muslim scholar Transat
an and a translator you can't say that
he's not a scholar no yes yes you can
say he's a scholar of Arabic but it's
okay cuz we we just traing Scholars at
this point so so so here's the point of
this right here here's the point the
point is is that you said theel is in
Matthew Mark Luke John you know and
whatever agrees with the Quran that's
how you know the TR that what okay got
you so here's my question to you okay
sure um how do you know what language
Jesus spoke spoke AR how do you know
that through through theil okay so how
do you know that that's true because
there's nothing that um there's nothing
that clashes with Islam that where does
the Quran agree that Jesus spoke
Aramaic I mean there's nothing it's
neutral it's neutral it doesn't it
doesn't go against it's not it's not for
I it's neutral it's neutral it's a
language it's it's neutral but however
this is what you said you said how you
know what's true in Matthew Mark Luke
and John is what pertain is what agrees
with the Quran okay that's what you said
however you're you just acknowledge that
in Matthew Mark Luke and John we see
that it's true that Jesus spoke Aramaic
okay you don't get that from the Quran
the Quran doesn't even affirm that well
no because if the Quran doesn't disagree
with it then that means it doesn't it's
not it's not false just because okay so
the Quran doesn't disagree with it so we
just changed it now so no no no whenever
whatever the whatever conforms with the
Quran but that doesn't but there's a
third category whatever is neutral is
neutral but you just added this now no
no no no no but in in general whatever
is neutral is neutral but but okay does
the Quran say you could drink fruit
juice specifically it says can you drink
no l to the criteria that you gave then
when I asked you you're playing a
semantic game using your words I guess
it's use your words you said you said
you said the way that we know what the
inil is is what agrees with the Quran
correct okay so you you said that Jesus
spoke Aramaic and you know that from the
inil the Quran doesn't agree from the
angel but okay okay so where else did
you get it from historians where where
Roman history if you studyed Roman
history there is historians who if you
study if you study a person who studies
Roman history so now it's not just the
guys hold on hold on hold on hold on I'm
only debating with you where's the
original brother brother guys guys let
him go brother so through Roman
historians people who have studied Roman
history know that they spoke Aramaic in
the areas the Israelites they spoke
Aramaic and the regions Galilee Samaria
and Jud where do they get that Jesus
himself spoke Aramaic okay from theel
thank you okay from the gospels okay
thank appreciate it because the gospels
are also a historical piece of evence
absolutely but the Quran doesn't agree
that Jesus spoke Aramaic nor does it
deny right like he said it's neutral but
you said that that's true right but you
know that that's true outside of the
Quran so you're saying that he him
speaking Aramaic is true in the inil I
could be wrong but I from what we know
now you could beong no no no but what we
know he spoke Aramaic but it's not a
matter of the belief it's not a matter
of belief if if he spoke or he didn't
speak this is irrelevant well no it's
very relevant why is it relevant to
believe ored I'm telling you why I'm
telling you why because you're saying
how you know what theil is and what it's
not when it comes to belief is what
agree no has nothing to do with belief
you said how we know what the inil is
and what it's not is based on what
agrees with the Quran but the Quran does
not agree that Jesus spoke Aramaic yet
you say that's true the Quran is silent
on it and it doesn't contradict the
Quran by default then it could agree so
no it's not it could by default dis age
if no it can by default disagree because
if they say if there's something that
goes against the Quran or it's false
then the Quran doesn't stand on lies it
doesn't approve of Lies see that's a
presupposition no it's not a
presupposition you're playing a semantic
game and I'm playing it back at you just
because the Quran is silent just because
the Quran doesn't say Jesus spoke
Aramaic doesn't mean that Jesus didn't
speak arame it's a neutral thing it has
nothing to do with cre that's not my
point my point is is that the only way
that you know he spoke arah comes from
the inil but what come what's coming
from the injil here is not talked about
by the Quran you said that you know what
the inil is when it comes to Bel when it
comes to Bel now is see now another go
what is the Quran but what is the Quran
it's a revelation of God we need to know
what the revelation of God this please
let me land this please go ahead so now
another criteria has been brought into
this at first it was simply what agrees
with the Quran now that's not enough now
it's whatever the Quran may be neutral
about as well but now that's not enough
because you're playing aan game now it's
another thing okay so you're I have to
qualify it because you keep playing on a
semantic game I'm I'm playing on your
own words historians also say that that
in that area that could have spoke Greek
Hebrew Aramaic so how do you like how do
you like this so irrelevant sorry so the
point the point is is that you know that
Jesus spoke Aramaic from the inil even
though the Quran doesn't say that I
could be wrong about his you can't
because you know that's a historical
fact so I'm saying the Quran doesn't so
if you know that it's not the Quran that
what theil is the the Quran is silent on
this matter so it's something that is
but you said it's in the inil when okay
if it's in the inil right so look I'm
using logic it's not a matter exactly
this this is my point this is my point
if the evidence is there for something
this means that the Quran is not the
basis on what the injil is or isn't it's
it's exclusive from the Quran no no no
no I because it's neutral cuz it Doesn't
contradict him speaking Aramaic doesn't
contradict Islamic beliefs or the Quran
so it's not it's it's a neutral about
what contradicts it here it is again the
fact that you know that Jesus spoke
Aramaic in the inil is separate from the
Quran it like the Quran doesn't speak on
this at all yet you take this as true in
the you you said you know that this is
true in the let me qualify no no wait
wait whatever goes let do this I'll let
you do this in a second okay I'm just
going off of what we buil done so far
okay okay so when you said that what we
know agrees with the Quran that's how we
know what the inil is yet Jesus speak
speaking aric in the injil is separate
from the Quran but you still said that
that's true in the injil so you was able
to identify something in the inil that
the Quran doesn't say anything about
because it doesn't go against the Quran
so that means that the Quran is not the
basis for what the injil is of course it
is because when it comes to belief in
what is true about Jesus we have to look
at the Quran but if you're talking about
some third irrelevant Point like did did
Jesus speak Aramaic or not that's a
historical piece of evidence that has
nothing to do with belief in God and
belief in Jesus and what's Revelation
and what's not this is a third point it
could very well be that he didn't speak
aramic it wouldn't change what the ngel
is and what the ngel isn't all right
last point on this last point on this
because because I got to go M late go
ahead go ahead go so you said that the
Quran is used to judge the previous
scriptures yeah a supreme authority over
it got it so when the Quran tells
Muhammad if he's doubting now please
don't waste time on this I'm not saying
that he was doubting it's a if so if he
was in doubt it says about about what
has been revealed to you then go and ask
the people who've been reading the
scripture before you why does he tell
him to go ask the people who's reading
the scripture before him if he has
doubts about the Quran beautiful he
doesn't have doubts about the Quran but
but but but he goes back to the
scripture brother do you know what that
particular verse was revealed in um
context why it was
revealed yes why he was given stories
about the previous prophets no that's
not why what it is no it isn't it's the
verse about stoning because they say why
do the Jews come to you when they when
you're quoting a different verse I
thought that's the verse you're talking
about no the verse I'm talking about is
1094 star rain man yeah what you're
talking about is 543 where he says why
do they come to you for judgment when
they have the Torah that's not what I'm
talking about okay which one are you
talking about4 I'm not familiar so
I got you
man I got you you become Muslim one day
so why is it that if he's in doubt about
the Quran not saying that he was but
Allah says if if you're in doubt about
the Quran then go ask the people who've
been reading the scripture before you
why would he send them to the previous
scriptures if he has doubts about the
Quran because because he was he was
prophesized in the in the Deuteronomy
1818 so basically so going back to the
previous scriptures would verify the the
Revelation that he's getting right
correct okay so that would mean that
what he's getting is true because it
lines up with what came before right
correct so if it if what he got if what
he was getting didn't line up with what
why why is your boy so animated bro he's
so animated bro what are you trying to
do bro so animated you're distracting
all right so all right so pay attention
he was doing a little thing with his
hands and I was looking behind me I'm
like what's going on man so we're we're
in the heat of this We're In the Heat of
this so so all right do we have to cut
it short
rain all all right we got to
get let's finish on this let's go so so
if the Quran lines up with what they
what what came before he knows that it's
that he's receiving the truth so here's
my question if the Quran didn't line up
with what came before then he would know
that what he's receiving is a lie
right I see where you're going with this
but it but the thing is answer the
question but the Quran is the again
going back to that verse Quran is the
question please but it does coincide
with what
doesn't if if again if what he's
receiving doesn't line up with what came
before that means he's receiving the
Quran is also a supreme authority over
the previous scpt yes it does it says M
you don't want to accept that because
then it would then you have no argument
because it says it's a supreme authority
over it it could destroy your whole
argument it destroys your whole AR let's
go with this let's say the Quran is a
supreme authority over the previous
scriptures corre so if Muhammad's
doubting about about the Quran not
saying that he was but if if he's
doubting about the supreme authority why
would he go to a lesser authority to
verify the Supreme one because there is
because things there are things in the
Old Testament and New Testament that
align with the Quran the basic princi B
basic principles so basically the the
lower Authority can verify the superior
listen listen yes of course so then that
means the lower no no no no no no one
can verify another no no no don't don't
do your little St looking anything
that's tough truth is truth no matter
where it is truth is truth no matter
where it is that's tough truth is truth
no matter where it is truth is truth no
matter where it is wrap up to wrap up
goad okay so truth is truth wherever it
is and Truth exists in the Old Testament
truth exists in the New Testament and
Truth exists in the Quran the the only
thing that we're taught about that we're
taught about these scriptures is that
the Quran is the one that is fully
preserved since the time it was revealed
we don't have the Torah in its original
form we don't have the inil in its
original form and I could actually prove
this by you know one John 5:7 then the
King James vers is not actually there
the stoning of the of the adulteress is
not actually there the Torah was written
800 years after Moses because it
predicts Mo because it because it talks
about Moses's death and no man knows
where Moses's grave is there's so many
reasons to believe that the Old
Testament and the New Testament aren't
in its original form and why would God
send down a scripture that's not in its
original form that is susceptible to
corruption and why wouldn't you believe
in a revelation that was given to a
prophet and it's preserved and it's
promised in the book that it's preserved
and we have the Birmingham manuscripts
that prove till this day that the Quran
is 100% what was revealed to the prophet
Muhammad so with that being said allahar
all right thank you for that all right
for my last one
all right all right all right so so to
wrap up guys first of all let's give a
hand to samur right am I saying yes yes
thank you for having me on Avery and you
too my brother Z Zacharia all right nice
thanks thanks for the I don't I don't I
don't hate Avery he's actually he's
actually a cool dude if he kicks me off
again I'm I'm a
ha so let me let me let me do my he's my
brother in humanity so let's give all a
round of applause for Avery as well man
thank you guys thank you guys so let me
do my wrap up guys so um so as you saw
in the discussion man we see that
there's a lot of inconsistencies all
right no matter which way you go if you
say that the Quran is the supreme
authority then why would Muhammad be
have to go to a lower authority to
verify the Supreme one that literally
makes no sense so that destroys that
altogether so then this would mean that
if Muhammad's in doubt about the Quran
go ask the people who've been reading it
before the scripture before you that
means the scriptures that came before is
the supreme authority that verifies the
Quran so if the Quran is not in line
with those that means the quran's a lie
and Muhammad would know that he's
actually not a real Prophet this is how
we this is the Dilemma of Islam the
Islamic dilemma is that the Quran
affirms the previous scriptures as
authoritative yet it contradicts them
which shows that the Quran is false now
if the Bible's corrupted then the Quran
is still false because the Quran affirms
corrupted scripture it's a d man it's a
d the Quran is consistent that God is
one already did it right so um just just
just as you guys saw it we see we see
what the Quran says we see what the
Bible says everybody do your research
look at the verses that we talked about
and uh you know let me know in the
comments section what you guys thought
man what you guys think about our guest
here did he get make good arguments did
he bring good uh did he represent
himself well uh you know I wanted all
the all the Muslims and the Christians
to engage right thanks for coming
appreciate it we'll see you guys next
time oh my God logic
[Music]